the question is based on this expansion
the question is and it's phrased in one
of two ways either the way the question
in this case said it find the term that
is independent of X find the term that
is independent of X in this expansion or
alternatively the other way it said is 0
know what's the other way that you just
said find the the constant term right
all the coefficients thought they
already so in other words there's a
whole bunch of these terms that all have
X's of them but there's a single term
with no exit search so what is it ok now
the way I begin with is I want to
actually just write out the expansion
just in basic form not every single term
just enough of them to get the pattern
ok that's all I'm after if you want to
think back to all we did applications to
series and sequences you know when
you're like I'm paying off this thing
and I say what's the amount after one
what's the amount after 21 step out
after 3i get the pattern and then I
generalized and I say what's the amount
after em months or 10 years or whatever
it is ok so what I'm about to riot is
the equivalent of those first three
lines they help me make sure I nail down
the nth term and I don't confuse I don't
have an off by one error which is what a
common thing TT ok so how should i write
this what's the first term in this
expression what am I going with thinking
back to my nokia theatre what's the
first thing i write down I'm gonna write
6c not ok now i cant right what what in
fact is the value of 60 not because how
many ways if you've got if you have six
objects how many ways are there of
choosing none of them and the answer is
one way here it is okay so six c0
anything c0 is just one but the point is
like I want to develop a pattern
remember well perhaps I'm not going to
write one I want to write the thing that
helps me identify the pack which is
after that you then have a combination
of these terms right some of these some
of these Bennett this is the very first
term I'm going to write it as this guy I
have six of them right that's the most
this guy remembers got a lighter side
attached to it
2 x to the 4 good buddy this guy be the
first term there are none of you yep
it's at a case you see I'm forming the
pattern here now all of that work will
be making the next bits really really
easy when I go to the next term this
will be 61 looks just six how many x
squared turns out it there will be one
less which is five and how many by this
to on X to the 4 turn on it just the one
dot dot okay with my last turn how does
this series are it is a series has the
series finish get the last part of
Pascal's triangle all the way to the end
I'm going to have how many of the x
squared toes by this time none of them
they're all gone and then you get left
with all of the minus 2 and X to the
fortune at six of them okay excellent so
there is the entire series now what I'm
after is there's a particular term in
here where these guys are these guys are
going to cancel out that's what I'm
after now as was mentioned before we
started this is a sufficiently low
number that you could probably just work
out by trial and error in fact it to the
next term and what the number is okay
however like I said that's not a very
good technique it doesn't generalize
very well because if i make make the
number figure this number here or if i
made these more icky like putting some
fractures or something like that it's
much harder to just think about it you
need a more systematic approach okay so
here's what I'm good of you i'm going to
say the n plus 1 term now the reason why
i say n plus 1 is because when i look at
this term here i would call this the
first term okay ah this is the first
term that's the second term and so on
this is the seventh term but the number
are going to be putting into this to
make it work is zero do you see that
I've got a quiz zero in there I could
alternatively i couldn't call this the
eighth term and then in here i'm going
to put n minus 1 but that's a bit nikki
i prefer to do it this way either way
it's fine you can even call this the 0th
term if you're comfortable with that
what's important is that you
I clear feed yourself so when I've got T
at n plus 1 i'm going to have 6 cm this
is my first term right I've got an equal
zero for all of these bits when is this
next up it come from this six you go six
and then 5 4 3 2 1 06 yeah it starts
with six and you take away which you
have a turbulent right so 6 minus n 6-0
in this case and then you've got these
guys who you learn and there's just n of
them which in this first term is 0 there
are none of them okay so that's an N
plus 1 term and when you have a look at
this what I'm after is there is some
terms such that this one and this one
their collective power will be 0 right
that will be independent of X so in
order to try and tease that out like
these are separate at the moment but I
need to combine them together so the
indices can talk with each other right
so I just have to be a little careful
with my index laws this guy is going to
hang out the photos their relevance
really until we work out what the actual
lover is here I just could use power of
a car right so this is going to be X to
the power of Thomas 200 multiplies
across here I'm going to separate this
out this minus to the M doesn't affect
the X so I'm just going to like them
separately and then what do I have here
this is on the denominator so i'm going
to write hymns x to the power of minus 4
and he's got an end also coming along
for the ride you see that so I've got my
one two three four pieces the pieces
that I want to interact with each other
of these guys so again being careful
with my index laws I'll write these
coefficients at the front because
they're just going to be done this here
I've got 12 minus suit and what happens
when i multiply numbers are the same
base i add their indices right so this
is going to be X to the power of 12 Fred
ok so here you can now see like the mats
are starting to a fault i do want to
explain what i'm doing them because I
not always trying to find the closer
terms and Tom's unplugged your other
things like find the greatest
coefficient i'm going to write for
constant term or for the term
that is independent of X we want the
index to be zero okay that make sense so
in other words 12-6 and equal zero set
and of course is equal to gym ok now the
wonderful thing about the way that we've
set this up is that I've done all the
legwork up here like this is something
which just tried to guess at it makes it
a little bit harder if I know that I
just need to supply it in here I even
know exactly what's going to happen to
this it's just going to vanish away
that's right it's going to become one so
therefore it's actually turn three is
the one that after the third term and
it's going to be 62 tires lives two
square I suppose I could put one for me
in there okay now 62like never know if
you know your Rose well enough this is
16 15 20 I think it is but I didn't go
that far it's only the third term right
so one then six then 15 obviously your
calculator can tell you this as well and
minus 2 squared is 4 so there is the
constant term that I was off by the
greatest coefficient yeah okay so that
is a little bit more tricky then you
have to look at this guy this is the
important part right and what you need
to do if you remember I did a question
on this before I'm not going to right
now but I'm having to do another one if
you find more for me on to the actual
mechanics of it wait you need to form an
equality between this and your series of
terms and at some point you find terms
are like if you remember if you just
start with the coefficients like this is
the next one 20 20 30 sweaty and then 20
I think to make it the number of turns
right 72 yeah so that's not right well
it's only 120 yes yeah the next one is
35 35 so here you can see that naturally
the coefficients are kind of doing this
right they start off small they're big
in the middle and then they get small
again right but depending on these guys
guys hear this some perfectly
symmetrical horrific will sort of
leaning this way or that way for
instance you can see here on this
particular question the last one is in
fact going to e let's think about this
lucky for us this is quite nice and
simple so that's not going to contribute
anything so in terms of just magnitude
because that's what the greatest means
this is going to be 1 2 4 8 16 32 64
okay so then you're comparing the
products that you get here now I am
guessing that probably this is the one
I'm going to be interested in I'm just
guessing you can calculate the numbers
obviously but forming this product here
you're going to get a relationship
between it okay when does it get bigger
when is again smaller and that's another
classic question but it starts off in
much the same way you start to get to
this point but then you do something
different afterwards okay is it is i
right is it this one yeah because six x
32 is clustering 898 yeah that's the
small okay this is easily obviously
small okay so yeah you can see you could
obvious there's an obvious crashing okay
um does he know any questions on them
you saw the way i set it up like i said
this step here people like lots of
people for good reasons don't like this
step it's time consuming to do this step
but it's also time consuming to do these
steps and we still do them because they
make sure that you really nail this
right are the most common error that
students make is that when they form
this line it's I've at number one off by
one or these things are like swapped
around in some way and therefore people
get the wrong indices out here they get
the wrong term and then everything looks
okay because you can still evaluate a
term but of course you didn't who's
going to actually check me all the
numbers and it's not going to work out I
just want to see this medicine yeah yeah
they're okay because because it's a
symmetrical series that's okay but there
are others like for example the sighing
people get that wrong there are all
kinds of little traps and things to make
mistakes about that this line up here I
find every student who write this gets
the next slide right so it's a very very
good indicator okay